Hello, internet. I'm Gav.
I'm Dan.
We've been trying to do this video
for a long time.
Last time we tried it, this happened.
Oh, my god!
I burned my hand, didn't I?
Yeah, you did.
So now we have changed location,
we've got a more powerful cooker
and it's really windy,
which makes it even more dangerous
than the last time we did it.
So, basically, this
video is what not to do
in an oil fire situation.
If you have a load of that is on fire,
don't throw water on it,
because the water sinks through the oil,
evaporates immediately
on the surface of the pan
and throws all the oil upwards
in a big flaming, hot, melty mess.
And you'll burn, yeah.
You will burn.
So I'm taking more precautions this time
with a face mask
and standing up-wind of the fire.
All right.
Get that oil on.
That's enough.
Bloody hell!
You reckon?
Yeah.
It's on fire?
Bloody hell.
Get the propane out then.
Okay, that's it.
Go for it.
Dan, that was amazing.
Yeah, it's unbelievable.
Amazing, slash terrifying.
Scary.
You may have noticed
that we are actually
five thousand miles away
from where we shot that video.
But, it's quieter here.
And it's greener.
And there's less wind.
Our original audio was ,
wind noise.
So, we are doing another outro.
If you wanna put out an oil fire,
don't throw water on it.
Soak a towel, a dish towel or a tea towel,
put it over the top of the pan
and it should go out.
Also, don't, sort of, pour the oil
onto your hand, like I
did in the previous video.
Don't do that either.
Right there.
That was right over there.
Yeah. Don't do that.
Feel free to use this in a fire-training,
educational video, if you
see this and want to use it.
That's fine.
Follow us on Twitter if you want.
Buy a shirt. We got free shirts.
And we will see you in the next video.
Thanks for watching.
How's your scar now?
It's not too bad. Oh, no, it's this hand.
Look, you can see it still.
Let's have a look.
Let's have a close-up.
It's like this circle
here is the main patch.
It healed up well.
Yeah, not bad.
I'm impressed with it.